from the studio who's not exactly known
for tastefully handling other culture
stories
comes the 25th anniversary of a middle
eastern fairy tale
that would never be made today praise
allah
aladdin journey to agrabah
an ancientish arabish land ruled under
strict sharia law
do you know what the penalty is for
stealing
and meet jasmine a princess struggling
with the ultimate first world problem
i don't want to be a princess anymore
she's a strong independent woman
who won't let herself be married off
like a piece of property
until she meets a sexy bad boy watch her
slum it up with aladdin
a hunky thief with no home no parents
and no nipples who steals food and gives
it to even smaller cuter orphans
oh so sweet together they'll create the
most realistic love story in disney
history
as the guy asks the girl to trust him do
you trust me do you trust me
then says whatever it takes to get into
her mc hammer pants
tell her that
and at the end of it all must face the
consequences of his pathological lying
by getting everything he ever wanted
sit back as robin williams takes over
the film as the magical genie
who's so powerful he does impressions of
people who won't be born for hundreds of
years
be ever impressive i can't believe it
i'm losing to a rug
right here for your very much wish
fulfillment all right sparky here's the
deal
i can't bring people back from the dead
kids just love a good peter laurie enjoy
his non-stop
improvised riffing that made him
everybody's favorite part of the film
and every disney animator's worst
nightmare the exits are here
here here here here here anywhere oh
they're poor poor hands
conspiring against them is jafar whose
goatee
black robes and snake staff should
really dip people off that he's evil
the princess will make me
and his accomplice iago i can't take it
anymore who is now the second most
famous bird gilbert godfried has ever
voiced
i flack follow along on an adventure
that made people spend way too much time
thinking about what they'd spend their
three wishes on
and taught kids that it's not how rich
you are but what's inside that counts
if by inside you mean inside a magical
app that can make you rich
so get ready for a movie that if it
weren't for the genie and the music
would be pretty by the numbers but man
is that genie funny
and then is that music good featuring
unforgettable songs like
the narrator song a framing device for
this whimsical tale the credits will
go much faster you know so the young
kids won't bear
the telling kids it's okay to steal song
ceiling expired if you need it
get yours forget the police feed me or i
will disturb the peace
where did you get a french
that's how cartoon bread straw
the take your kid to the bathroom song
time to pee
nothing to see release your agua
wash your hands zip up your pants you
can trust me
aladdin's turned to a prince don't worry
it'll make sense
no need to whine anymore your kid can
pee
the kidnapping your date song i just
kidnapped this
girl cause her midriff is sexy
we are up here now let's see if she'll
rub my lamp tonight i'll pork this girl
as long as that's okay with you
no creepy long-faced dudes or family
foods
to keep us both from corki
your sentient rug can watch us too
you are so much
without his mask
cause i'll always be
you ain't never gonna recast me
starry allyer blue jasmine
maleficent the original angry bird
curious abou the hardest level in the
super nintendo game
really ties the room together and robin
screen time
a genie
that jasmine is so hot right guys maybe
the hottest disney princess ever
well guess what she's 15 years old don't
you feel gross now
well at least it's okay for aladdin to
oh
be sure to subscribe for more honest
trailers
thanks to our friends at paperbot for
their awesome music
click the link below to check out their
brand new channel and tell them screen
junkie sent you
i'm a pretty pancake made of flowers
oodles of noodles for my pet poodles
literally little italy i'm gonna deck
you in the schnoz
the f word i'm made of ice cream